[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce set 8
litres d'eau au sommaire de ce vendredi
24 octobre le mouvement démocratique du
nid lancent un pacte d'engagement pour
les élections municipales de 2020 un
document destiné aux candidats des
candidats qui souhaitent solliciter le
soutien du mouvement créé l'office
national des forêts s'engage dans le
zéro phyto qu'en abandonnant tout
recours à leurs alter by side
insecticides et fongicides
nous ferons le point sur les forêts
divine oise avec notre invité de
nombreuses actions pour l'emploi une
semaine de la parentalité
clayes-sous-bois et un belge victorieux
de son troisième open de france
nous reviendrons sur ce qui a marqué
l'actualité cette semaine dans le
département
et avant de commencer cette édition
n'oubliez pas le passage à l'heure
d'hiver qui aura lieu dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche dimanche à 3 heures du
matin il sera donc deux heures et c'est
peut-être l'une l'une des dernières fois
qu'on ferait ce geste de recul et les
aiguilles de votre montre en effet en
mars 2019 les eurodéputés ont voté pour
la suppression de ce changement d'heure
saisonniers suite à une consultation 83
% des participants se sont exprimés en
faveur de la fin du changement d'heure
une mesure qui pourrait devenir
effective en 2021
reste aux états membres de décider s'ils
choisissent l'heure d'été où l'heure
d'hiver
[Musique]
le mouvement démocrate des yvelines le
modem organisé ce matin une réunion dans
sa permanence à versailles
objectif les municipales de 2020 avec un
pacte d'engagement
à ce jour trois candidats sont investis
pour le parti pour les prochaines
élections
reportage de réduire 11 démocratie
participative développer le vivre
ensemble transition écologique et devoir
d'exemplarité
voici les principes du pacte
d'engagement municipal du modem un
document destiné aux candidates et
candidats qui souhaitent solliciter le
soutien du mouvement pour le scrutin en
2020 nous aujourd'hui on veut pas
aborder ces élections comme une élection
nationale je crois que les français les
évinois ne le souhaite pas c'est pas une
élection des sikhs est loin de là
aujourd'hui nous on veut bâtir des
rassemblements et porter des projets
pour les communes avec des partenaires
historiques et des nouveaux partenaires
ce qu'on veut faire surtout c'est porter
des projets citoyens dans les communes
et poursuivre le maillage territorial
pour les modèles ont à ce jour dans les
communes de plus de 9000 habitants 19
chefs de file ont été désignés ils ont
un rôle de référent du mouvement dans
leur commune par ailleurs trois
candidats ont été investis par le
conseil national du mouvement démocrate
à villepreux maisons laffitte et le chez
nero concours
porter une manière nouvelle et faire de
la politique et notamment parce que
c'est vraiment un sujet que nos
concitoyens à peine leurs voeux 2
porter des propositions sur la
transition écologique en fait sur cette
commune qui est une commune nouvelle
pour la première élection en cas de
victoire les candidats ayant signé le
pacte s'engagent à exercer leur mandat
selon les principes qui leur groupe à
partir du lundi 28 octobre le conseil
départemental du modem se réunira tous
les mois pour statuer sur les demandes
de soutien et d'investiture le 14
octobre dernier l'office national des
forêts faisait entrer en vigueur sa
décision du démarche zéro traitement
phytopharmaceutiques rappelant dans son
communiqué de presse la volonté de
s'inscrire dans la transition écologique
déjà en 2018 le nf abandonné le
glyphosate particulièrement contestée
michel béal vous êtes le directeur de
l'onec ile de france ouest bonjour dont
j'ai alors pourquoi cette décision
qu'est-ce que ça va changer ça va
changer on va avoir des forêts bio 100%
bio on utilisait très très peu le
glyphosate est très très peu déjà depuis
les dernières on a arrêté glyphosate
mais les autres produits agro
pharmaceutiques on les utilisait très
peu nous dans notre région ici dans les
yvelines
on l'utilisait plus déjà de plus aucun
depuis de très longues années
c'était encore utilisées de temps en
temps dans certaines autres régions de
france pour lorsque la forêt est fragile
qu'on a des jeunes plants des jeunes
plantations elle ces plantations sont
parfois envahi par des végétaux par de
la ronce par des fougères qui risque
d'étouffer ces jeunes plants et donc
c'était les rares fois on l'utilisé
aujourd'hui partout en france ça ne sera
plus utilisée et donc on ne va utiliser
d'autres moyens de lutte pour faire en
sorte que ces jeunes plants on ne soit
pas envahis par d'autres végétaux vous
et qui était très peu utilisé
effectivement une enquête 2010 est
indiqué que seulement 0 02 % des
territoires surface tresserre public
était traité avec un herbicide alors par
quoi voulez remplacer tout simplement
par des travaux manuels et mécanique
c'est à dire que là où la forêt fragile
c'est quand ce sont des jeunes plants
donc il faut faire attention qu'il ne
soit pas étouffée par de l'air par de la
rose par de la fougère
donc on va reprendre des travaux plutôt
manuel dont
que des forestiers des ouvriers
forestiers avec des débroussailleuses à
la main et puis sinon entre les lignes
de plans parce que souvent ce sont des
plantations plutôt rectiligne on va
pouvoir aussi passer des petits
tracteurs avec des broyeurs pour passer
entre les lignes de plan il ya d'autres
mesures qui sont réfléchies pour appeler
pour une transition écologique
non aujourd'hui voilà le on utilisait
très peu on n'utilise plus du tout
j'allais dire c'est un autre domaine
mais aujourd'hui on se rend compte aussi
de plus en plus on est sollicité pour
des actions citoyennes des actions de
bénévolat hulu de volontariat rien à
voir avec évidemment les produits agro
pharmaceutiques mais c'est aussi d'aider
la bonne volonté
évidemment mes bêtes des bénévoles qui
viennent en forêt pour travailler donc
en ce moment on a depuis de longues
années déjà des opérations aux forêts
propres donc on ramasse à la main grâce
à des promeneurs grâce à des
associations
et puis cette année ici dans les
yvelines sur le che nez en forme et de
fausses reposes on à l'hiver qui vient
une opération de d'arrachage des plantes
invasives ces fameuses plantes qui sont
pas naturellement dans nos forêts c'est
des lauriers du caucase peut être
d'autres végétaux invasif et donc on
essaye de les éliminer c'est un gros
travail ça peut se faire un peu mais nak
mécaniquement mais aussi des
associations se mobilisent pour nous
aider pour aussi procédé à l'arrachage
de ces plans qui envahissent parfois les
sous bois
voilà donc c'est bien évidemment pas une
alternative aux produits agro
pharmaceutiques mais c'était l'occasion
pour moi aussi de citer ces actions
citoyennes comme on les appelle
justement la collaboration et les
associations on va y revenir on passe à
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
et justement lundi dans le sud fait
journal grégory canalaire recevait une
association celle des amis des forêts de
versailles et de fo se repose
ils ont transmis une lettre au préfet
pour demander le classement de la forêt
domaniale de versailles depuis 2000
hectares en forêt de protection
l'objectif étant de limiter
l'urbanisation cette forêt est
actuellement traversées par la nationale
12 la route départementale 91 une voie
ferroviaire et pourraient être touchés
par l'aménagement du projet du plateau
de satory
on écoute pierre desnos président de
l'association la protection empêche
qu'on viennent grignoter à nouveau ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas le faire
mais le la procédure administrative est
très compliqué et très long parce que
c'est le conseil d'état qui va valider
la protection et il y a que le conseil
d'état qui peut lever la protection dont
dès l'instant où il y a un projet il
faut que le conseil d'état donne son
aval michel le hénaff a apporté son
soutien à cette démarche
oui nous sommes favorables en tant que
gestionnaire on est dans une région où
les forêts ont parfois pour l'objet de
convoitises convoitises foncière la
région parisienne et cher en le foncier
est cher les forêts sont parfois le lieu
de grignotage comme je viens de le dire
le rappelait pierre desnos le président
des amis de la forêt de faut s'opposer
de versailles et donc le classement faut
être protection permet de bloquer les
prochains futurs éventuels projets
routiers autoroutiers d'infrastructures
diverses ou d'urbanisation et donc c'est
une protection du foncier forestier on
pourra pas transformer de la forêt en
zone urbaine ou ferroviaires par exemple
la forêt est aussi un lieu de loisirs et
notamment en cette période de l'année
avec la cueillette des champignons
mais attention près de 500 cas
d'intoxications liées à la consommation
de beauvais champignons ont été re tout
repenser ces deux dernières semaines les
autorités sanitaires appellent à la
vigilance
alors pour faire sa cueillette en toute
sécurité l'association des naturalistes
des yvelines propose des balades
encadrées
reportage en forêt de marly
l'accord tumeur du coup les paccots mais
cela avec son panier ses bottes en
caoutchouc mais va est venue accompagnée
de sa maman et ses cousines pour
apprendre à reconnaître les champignons
regarde comme s'efface regarde le pied
aussi aucune méprise possible le groupe
d'une vingtaine de personnes est encadré
par deux experts passionné de mycologie
membres de l'association des
naturalistes des yvelines qui propose
cette sortie avec l'office du tourisme
la première question en général c'est
savoir si c'est bon ou pas bon mais ce
qui est important avant avant cela bien
sûr c'est de reconnaître les champignons
puisque tous les tous ces champignons ou
des sosies
la famille va faire attention car elle
est venue avec un objectif bien précis
c'est qu'ils sont connectés basse et ça
on fait une âme est avec eva mais
précise néanmoins pour cela karina son
astuce elle prend en photo les
champignons pour s'assurer de bien les
reconnaître champignons ont roulé ça a
roulé on va demander au monsieur
enroulée mortels mais on va mettre ça
original parce que on a un peu
l'occasion de faire ça avec des experts
et est généralement leur on espère
cueillir qu'on sait pas trop si c'est si
ces taxis coupaye le met en champignon
va pouvoir se faire eva trouve le tout
1er septembre bordeaux de la balade on
déterre bien le champignon bon bien le
déterminer par contre là on peut enlever
la terre pour éviter de mettre de la
terre dans le panier donc enfin un petit
couteau et une à condition cependant de
ne pas les confondre
regardez les fip et ben non ça c'était
une feuille je me suis fait typiquement
je me suis fait avoir presque deux
heures de balade en forêt de marly pour
amener des paniers bien remplie dernier
coup d'oeil de l'expert avant de partir
alors c'est bien là c'est bien vérifier
ces champignons avant de les transformer
en anglais tout en fricassée un réflexe
à ne pas manquer les autorités
sanitaires appellent à la vigilance
suite à de nombreux cas d'intoxication
ces dernières semaines
alors là les champignons faut faire
attention à l'espèce que récolte aussi
un nom - oui bien sûr cette année c'est
plutôt une année plutôt importante il ya
beaucoup de champignons en forêt
peut-être après le sol plutôt chaud et
puis une pluie qui est venue assez
abondantes
oui la cueillette il faut la être
qu'elles sont modérés elle est tolérée
évidemment la cueillette dans les forêts
domaniales mais pour sa seule
consommation personnelle donc plusieurs
paniers ou des grands sacs
c'est anormal et si c'est pour faire du
commerce à la suite c'est interdit
autres activités la chasse est sûre si
on est en pleine saison et au laos et
les neuf législation qui est stricte et
qui varie selon les espèces oui oui oui
elles elles varient elles varient parce
qu'il ya des espèces qui sont soumis à
des plans de chasse il ya des espèces
qui sont déclarés nuisibles parce que
trop abondante donc les deux exemples
dans les grands animaux que l'on
retrouve dans les yvelines
c'est le cerf c'est le chevreuil et le
sanglier le le sanglier très abondant il
est classé nuisible dans le département
des yvelines comme dans bien d'autres
départements et il est particulièrement
abondants ça au niveau de la phrase
c'est peut-être l'une a été multiplié
par 25 le nombre de d'animaux qui sont
tués chaque année des sangliers tués
parce qu'on n'a pas d'autre choix dans
nos régions on n'a pas les prédateurs on
à pas de loup on n'a pas de lynx on n'a
pas d'ours évidemment est donc la seule
possibilité pour réguler c'est par la
chasse par des chasseurs et donc on a
besoin d'eux et on a besoin de cette
régulation pour que les forêts soient en
équilibre parce que une forêt peut pas
accueillir trop d'animaux parce qu'
après il ya des dégâts il ya des dégâts
à la forêt elle même et surtout quand
c'est du sanglier c'est des dégâts aux
cultures voisines dans les cultures
agricoles voisines et le risque de
collisions avec des voitures car les
animaux traverse des routes
en octobre ils ont ravagé certains
terrains notamment sur les communes
saint cyr l'école bois d'arcy et plaisir
le préfet a même autorisé que le
lieutenant de l'eau
toulouse est très incomplète
accomplissent des tirs de nuit alors à
sa s'opposer défenseurs des animaux et
sur cette question des sangliers une
pétition tourner sur internet depuis
début octobre la revue plus de 40 mille
signatures comment on fait pour
concilier ces deux parties pas simple
effectivement mais je pense qu'il faut
beaucoup communiquer beaucoup pensent
que les forêts sont peu giboyeuse parce
que les promeneurs sont d'abord des
urbains qui viennent on vit bien en
forêt mais ne connaissent pas le la
nature le son équilibre la présence de
cerf le chevreuil
ce sont des animaux qui sont farouches
qui sont furtifs on ne les voit pas
quand on est promeneurs simplement pour
faire un petit jogging ou pour marcher
avec des enfants et pourtant ils sont
bien là il leur suffit de peu de chose
d'un roncier dans le tas de ronces pour
se cacher et donc il faut communiquer je
pense la première des choses donc c'est
important de le dire plus qu'il n'ya
jamais eu en france plus qu'il n'y a
jamais eu et le nombre d'animaux de
grands animaux dessert des chevreuils et
des sangliers a jamais été aussi
important donc c'est ce qu'il faut que
de dire qu'il y en a plus ou qui en a
pas assez
et donc aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
dégâts l'onef a beaucoup travaillé sur
ces sujets là avec la fédération des
chasseurs des yvelines et des autres
départements de l'île de france pour
constater et partager un constat commun
que ce soit les massifs de rambouillet
du secteur de versailles la forêt de
port-royal de bois d'arcy de marly la
forêt de saint-germain un peu plus au
nord
toutes sont en excès de ces grands
animaux la loi 9 souhaite garder ses
forêts giboyeuses lecerf c'est un animal
en des mythes normal c'est normal qu'il
soit là notamment à rambouillet le
chevreuil également le sanglier aussi
mais aujourd'hui il ya une telle
abondance qu'il faut baisser les
populations l'onef le fait sur les
forêts domaniales par le biais de chasse
qui sont organisée planifiée
contrôlé par les neuf nous même en
dehors de la partie forêt domaniale
ce sont des refuges privé des forêts
privées donc là nous n'intervenons pas
c'est effectivement des propriétaires
eux-mêmes qu'ils le font ou dans des
zones qui sont non chassé le préfet qui
décide par le biais des lieutenants de
louveterie de réguler ces animaux dans
les zones non chassés comme honda autour
de versailles en a quelques-unes à côté
des forêts domaniales cela est bien
régulé merci michel perret halde est
venu sur le plateau on arrive à la fin
de cet entretien
je rappellerai directeur de l'office
national des forêts d'île de france
ouest qu on ouvre une page emploie à
présent pour sa cinquième édition du
forum emploi des jeunes la cfdt a choisi
de trappes toute la journée déjà n'ont
pu rencontrer des recruteurs et déposer
leur cv
nouveauté cette année une ouverture sur
l'apprentissage et l'alternance
théo est étudiant en communication il
recherche une alternance le stylo à
éviter c'est bien parce que les marques
c'est bizarre aussi peut dire que ça
attirera l'attention je trouve moi pour
mettre toutes les chances de son côté il
participe à un coaching personnalisé
pour perfectionner ses candidatures
c'est très intéressant en fait d'avoir
un avis de quelqu'un qui ne vous connaît
pas et qui va pouvoir juger de
votre performance de manière
extrêmement objective en fait souvent
les personnes que je vois sont trop
modestes ils mettent pas en avant leurs
qualités c'est incroyable
c'est vraiment incroyable
on zappe toutes les qualités après son
coaching chaque participant peut faire
le tour de la quarantaine de stands qui
composent le forum de l'apprentissage
organisé par la cfdt
pour cette cinquième édition le syndicat
a choisi trappe
notre objectif était vraiment de mettre
en relation les jeunes des quartiers
alors pas forcément défavorisés mais où
il y avait une certaine discrimination
et un fort taux de chômage pour leur
ouvrir notre réseau à
et leur faire mal
avoir un emploi un stage en alternance
cv en ligne
on n'aura pas de réponse en fait on est
devant la personne tout de suite et
appréhender notre cv du coup certains
types de 60 années l'événement en
partenariat avec pôle emploi on voit
plusieurs acteurs de l'emploi des
entreprises qui recrutent mais aussi des
associations comme aprodema elle propose
de découvrir les métiers de
l'agroéquipement on estime qu'ils nous
manquent à peu près 6000 emplois qui
restent non pourvus chaque année et en
général n'ont par exemple un jeune qui
informations dans les formations vos
équipements à la fin il entre deux et
trois offres minimum d'emploi pour ce
délit bien sûr lors de la dernière
édition du forum à nanterre 250
personnes avaient trouvé un emploi
pour la troisième édition de la semaine
de la parentalité plusieurs ateliers
étaient organisés aux clayes-sous-bois
parmi eux un atelier de massage pour
bébé à l'espace jacqueline auriol manon
par aldo a assisté à ce moment de
douceur on enlève les tensions angelo
semblent plus détendus et cela grâce au
massage sa mère katherine est venu
assister à cet atelier dirigé sous les
conseils de séverine on nous montre
qu'en d'accord alors qu'on se prépare en
frechaut flemmards petite pression sur
les pieds massage papillon pour les
jambes
la mère de famille apprend les bons
gestes pour un massage relaxant
il ne faut jamais lâcher le contact avec
son bébé lors du massage l'enfant doit
toujours vous sentir vous pouvez placer
vos pouces au niveau du front et vous
lis et un deux trois petits chefs et on
his fait sorcier
ils n'ont pas de sens ces massages
stimule le développement sensoriel il
est conseillé de les faire sur le lit
parental et d'instaurer un rituel
lumière tamisée et musicalement fond
c'est un massage bien-être par un
massage thérapeutique et
c'est surtout un moment privilégié avec
entre l'enfant et son parent des
massages aux visages sont également
appris lors de l'atelier ils peuvent
soulager notamment la poussée des dents
des tout petits la mer d'angelo profite
de ce moment de partage avec son fils
c'est pour créer un lien avec eux et que
sade et ça ça permet de se détendre
passâmes ont prévilégié ensemble et
faire une petite parenthèse dans la vie
du quotidien
ça m'a donné encore plus envie de
poursuivre dans ce sens là et puis de
d'apprendre de nouveaux gestes pour
masser mon bébé j'ai l'impression que ça
devait fait du bien donc c'est que du
bonheur un moment de douceur entre
parents et enfants qui se reproduira à
domicile après génération nous lie le
cmb le centre de musique baroque de
versailles a lancé le 17 octobre dernier
son nouveau projet la fontaine en scène
un projet d'une durée de deux ans auquel
les villes de trappes et de la verrière
sont associés ce projet
intergénérationnel et interculturel a
pour objectif notamment de faire
découvrir et interpréter aux habitants
des villes l'univers de jean de la
fontaine dont on fêtera d'ailleurs le
400e anniversaire de la naissance en
on a choisi la fontaine qui n'est pas un
musicien
parce que
ça nous semblait très intéressant de
travailler le texte
la musicalité du pot du de la poésie on
sait que la langue française la musique
française c'est le chant français c'est
d'abord un travail sur le sur le parler
sur le texte sur la clarté sur la clarté
et la déclamation
c'est un thème un sujet qui se prête à
des multiples interprétations et
réinterprétation puisque inde est un des
axes aussi du projet c'est de réécrire
des fable contemporaine avec notre
langage aujourd'hui nos préoccupations
d'aujourd'hui
sachant que l'homme reste l'homme à
travers les siècles et il est toujours
le même mais la forme les formes changer
peuvent se nourrir les unes des autres
et justement nous vous proposons de
revenir sur le projet initiateurs
génération luis est votre rubrique ça
s'est passé
[Musique]
ma forme et ses devoirs avez la patience
est content de voir que vous êtes
l'homme du monde paisible et plus j'ai
pas envie de voir ce matin dans la
chambre du roi on fait beaucoup
d'honneur monsieur dans la chambre du
roi un riche bourgeois qui veut devenir
un meuble une source de moquerie pro
molière lorsqu'il a écrit le bourgeois
gentilhomme ici monsieur jourdain et les
différents personnages sont joués par
des lycéens de trappes une découverte de
l'importance du costume du costume j'ai
fait qu sans apprêt corps m'a donné
qu'aux c'est sûr ça ça m'a mis plus à
l'aise par rapport au personnage tu as
tant mieux allez la paire et tim atb
morales personnages à tous qu'ils ont
préparé plusieurs scènes extraites de
bourgeois gentilhomme et l'exercice
s'étant
de le répéter une fois sans costume
comme dans le cadre d'une répétition et
une fois avec les costumes des costumes
là
une traditionnelle a déposé mi c'est
historique et de voir tout ce que ça
apportait à la fois pour le public donc
pour ceux qui observait la les
répétitions et pour les acteurs mise en
place par le centre de musique baroque
de versailles cet atelier s'inscrit dans
le projet génération du lit une
cinquantaine d'élèves ont pu se
familiariser avec l'univers de la
comédie est beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêt
surtout pour les costumes parce qu'ils
n'ont pas l'habitude sont quand même des
costumes a l'habitude de voir ni de
toucher ni manipulée et surtout pas
d'enfiler et donc ils ont été
effectivement très fin très surpris et
je pense toucher parce que ça fait
partie d'un certain patrimoine dans le
cadre de génération du lit près de 1000
trappistes sont invités à participer à
ce type de découverte une action
éducative artistique et culturelle qui
va durer jusqu'en 2018
[Musique]
le 103e open de france de golf s'est
achevée dimanche dernier au green sur
les greens du golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
mais quel est le me d'euros et patrick
jacq de dix neuf jeunes de dixmude vous
font revivre les quelques jours de
compétition dernier jour de compétition
de cet open de france 2019 ce dimanche
20 octobre
nicolas colsaerts a dispose de trois
coups d'avancé avant d'aborder le
dernier tour
le golfeur est le favori du public tiens
franco belge s'est peut-être nichols art
on verra mais il a du mal il admis mais
tout le monde a du mal aujourd'hui des
pronostics qui se sont avérées justes
nicolas colsaerts remporté au trou
numéro 18 cette édition 2010 9 son
premier titre depuis sept ans le golfeur
termine 12 coups sous le par avec un
coup d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
en conférence de presse le franco belge
de 36 ans mis ce moment avec sa famille
via son téléphone
c'est énormément de joueurs
[Musique]
voilà ça fait ça fait 18 ans que je suis
pro j'ai gagné deux fois j'aurais dû
gagner plus souvent comme je l'aï déjà
dit souvent elle fait de gagner chez
vous c'est génial j'ai joué un peu
l'impression de faire partie du paysage
golfique français
de leur côté les français n'ont une fois
de plus pas réussi à dompter ce parcours
de l'albatros les chefs de file de la
délégation française victor perez et
benjamin hebert termine 16e
c'est important pour que je connais bien
qui me résiste souvent a donc cette
année je suis content parce que j'ai
quand même réussi à faire une bonne
semaine
on les attend évidemment toujours encore
plus haut dans le leaderboard
mais indéniablement c'est une bonne
année pour le golf français sur
l'european tour avec victor perez qui
la tête là du camp français actuellement
talonnée par benjamin hebert on n'oublie
pas également les jeunes pousses comme
romain langue basque ou encore michael
lorenzo-vera cette 103e édition de
l'open de france de golf s'achève ici
sur le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
rendez vous l'année prochaine du 2 au 5
juillet à 2020 c'est la fin de cette
édition on se quitte avec des images de
l'exposition les toffes de ma garde-robe
à découvrir au musée de la toile de jouy
jusqu'au 23 février
le reportage complet est à retrouver sur
notre site internet
retour de votre actualité locale lundi
avec le 7-8 journal pour un week end sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]